on Prime crime
two deaths bring new questions for a
family Dynasty a lot of people respect
them but there are some people who fear
them the evidence
is a chicken the testimony he was pacing
back and forth and he said I got a bad
feeling and the incredible moments did
you kill Maggie
did you kill Paul no I did not kill Paul
thank you
hey there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases our next
story takes us to South Carolina where
controversy speculation and even death
surround one family
emergency
South Carolina June 7th 2021 1007 p.m
stop being up to it now it's fast
attorney Alec Murdock tells the 9-1-1
dispatcher that his wife 52 year old
Maggie and Son 22 year old Paul are shot
dead at their family property known as
Moselle
it's bad to take the buses Paul and
Maggie were found down at the kennels
Paul had been shot with a shotgun shot
in the chest first the Fatal injury was
to his head Maggie meanwhile suffered
five gunshot wounds from what they said
was a 300 Blackout rifle using that type
of ammunition they are dead
yes sir that's what that's what it looks
like but who could have done this
in order to understand the murders we
have to understand a bit more about the
Murdoch family the Murdoch family has
been prominent in the low country of
South Carolina for a century three
generations of Murdoch's prior to Alec
Murdock were solicitors basically the
prosecutors they were basically the face
of law enforcement in that Community a
lot of people respect them and Revere
them but there are some people who fear
them controversy rumors and even deaths
surrounded the Murdoch family such as
the sudden demise of their family
housekeeper Gloria Satterfield in 2018.
according to what Alex told the
insurance adjuster that his dogs greeted
her at the top of the step which caused
her to fall backwards and that's the
only known statement of that
then there's the mysterious death of 19
year old Stephen Smith found on a South
Carolina Road in 2015. the state
troopers who were on the scene that
morning didn't believe this was a hit
and run his shoes would have been blown
off there would have been skid marks
there would have been some debris so I
think it was blunt force trauma and I
think he was dumped off in the middle of
the road he was an openly gay teenager
and he had attended High School there in
Hampton with Buster Murdoch Randy
Murdoch Alec Murdoch's older brother
apparently reached out to Sandy Smith
the mother of Stephen and said I will
offer to represent you and Sandy Smith
really didn't understand why she would
need any representation at that point
Alex and Randy either one or both were
on the scene how would he know to show
up to an accident scene Buster says that
he had nothing to do with his murder
I'll take him at his word but there's
something else from the Murdoch past
something from 2019 that Alec
immediately mentions to first responder
Sergeant Green this is a long story my
son was in a boat wreck a few months
back he's been getting threats I noticed
somebody I know that's what it is Paul
Murdock and his friends went out they
were in his father's boat there were
people on the boat who said let me drive
if you've had too much to drink and you
know the reports we've heard was that
Paul said no this is my vote the boat
then crashes that resulted in the death
of Mallory Beach he was indicted on
boating while under or the influence is
it possible Paul and Maggie were
murdered by enemies of the family
fast forward almost three months after
the killings 9-1-1 receive another call
from Alec
Murdock's emergency I start I got a flat
tire
somebody stopped to help me
and when I turned my back they tried to
shoot me
oh okay well you shot yes people start
to think oh my God like somebody is out
to kill this family
but as you're about to see
sometimes in cases things aren't exactly
what they seem Days Later Alec Murdock
comes clean
and says you know what
some guy didn't shoot me I asked Curtis
Eddie Smith this guy I know to shoot me
so
your intent was to have him kill you so
he can collect you if you'd like
insurance right so my son could I mean I
knew I was about to lose everything I
wanted to commit suicide or be assistant
in committing suicide so my son Buster
could get 10 million dollars from a life
insurance policy I've been really really
sick in a sincerely apologize again for
lying to y'all Alec Murdock admits I've
had an opioid addiction for years and so
he fesses up and he's arrested for this
and when investigators dig deeper they
find that Alec Murdock was not the man
that the community thought him to be
indictments come out for Alec charges
for a number of financial crimes tax
evasion stealing from clients stealing
from the law firm Alec Murdoch would
eventually be charged with over 90
Financial related crimes including
embezzlement money laundering and
conspiracy but what else could he behind
could he in any way be behind the
killings of Maggie and Paul did you kill
Maggie did I kill him yes no baby did
you kill Paul no I did not kill Paul
foreign
[Music]
on June 7th 2021 Maggie and Paul Murdock
are found shot to death on their family
property in South Carolina
Maggie's husband and Paul's father Alec
Murdock calls 9-1-1 to report
discovering their bodies
we got medical guys what are they doing
can they hurry while Alec initially
appears to be an innocent victim during
the course of the investigation it's
revealed he had been stealing from his
law firm and clients and orchestrated a
suicide plot to conduct insurance fraud
as he was criminally charged for these
alleged Financial crimes the question
became is he hiding something else is it
possible he was behind the killings too
do you think I killed Maggie I have to
go where the evidence and the fact thank
you through a series of interviews with
law enforcement Murdoch lays out his
activities on the night of the murders I
was up at the house I laid down took a
nap on the couch I left to go to my
mom's when I got back to the house the
house was obviously nobody was in there
so I figured they're still up here
fooling around I pulled up and I could
see him and you know I knew something
was bad there are some odd things though
about Alec Murdock for instance the
footage you're seeing is from a Snapchat
video that was taken off of Paul's phone
earlier in the night before the murders
now compare that to what Murdoch is
wearing later on in the evening after
the killings
a point in that even if you change
clothes I'm not sure no one knows what
happened to that blue shirt that Alec
was wearing in the Snapchat video and
let's talk about that timeline of the
night the celebrate analysis shows that
Maggie Murdoch's phone locked at 8 49 PM
so did Paul Murdoch's phone it doesn't
appear that either one of them pick up
their cell phones again based on the
cell phone data investigators believe
the killings happened between 8 49 and
906 pm and they also say someone
possibly the killer was manipulating
Maggie's phone before throwing it on the
side of the road where it's ultimately
found after nearly an hour of no
activity Murdoch's phone suddenly
records a flurry of steps before he
drives away from the property and in
fact data from Murdoch's car not only
shows him driving past the location
where Maggie's phone was tossed but so
much more the data also Alec Murdock is
at his mother's home for about 15 to 20
minutes how long would you say you were
[Music]
actually five minutes an hour and
speaking of questionable comments to
police there was this exchange that had
a lot of people talking it was just so
bad I did it so bad you know it sounds
like they did him so bad
but a lot of other people thought he
said I did them so bad that would be
tantamount to a confession however
let's go back to Murdoch's Alibi so they
left and went down to the kennels and
what did you do once once Maggie and
Paul left I stayed in the house okay and
I was watching TV
looking at my phone and I actually fell
asleep on the couch okay he was with his
family he took a nap he goes to his
mom's
mom said he had
to go back down here after dinner until
his return trip from visiting your
mother
yes sir late in the investigation
authorities find something hidden on
Paul's phone a video recorded at 8 44 PM
approximately five minutes before
prosecutors say Maggie and Paul were
shot a video that changes this whole
story
quick cash
it's a guinea it's a chicken
quit
at 8 44 pm he told law enforcement he
was asleep so this totally blows up his
timeline and his alibi
it was the single most important piece
of evidence it's Paul speaking from the
grave on July 14 2022 Alec Murdock was
officially indicted for the murders of
Paul and Maggie Murdoch up next a trial
unlike any other the gallery was packed
people were lining up at two in the
morning to make sure that they got a
spot
[Music]
it's January 2023 the start of the
murder trial of Alec Murdock the once
prominent South Carolina attorney now
accused of shooting to death his wife
Maggie and Son Paul on their family
property back in June of 2021. the same
man who was separately charged with
dozens of financial related crimes for
stealing money from his Law Firm clients
and the government this trial was
watched by the nation as the prosecution
and the defense battled it out about 8
50 p.m and the defendant over there Al
Murdock took a 12-stage shotgun and shot
him just moments later
he picked up a 300 Blackout
and opened fire on his wife Maggie
family weapons were used to murder
Maggie and Paul the murder weapons were
never found but the examiner from sled
did say he believed the same 300
Blackout rifle that killed Maggie
Murdock was likely the same 300 Blackout
rifle that had fired 300 Blackout rounds
up by the house months prior prosecutors
would present the case that Murdoch had
the means and opportunity to kill his
family on their property they pinpointed
his questionable activities through
phone and car data suggesting he moved
quickly to cover his tracks in Alibi but
they also argued that Murdoch lied to
investigators I was probably going an
hour and a half from my mom's
about 15 to 20 minutes 20 minutes and
prosecutors would also claim Murdoch
tried to influence the accounts of key
Witnesses he was pacing back and forth
in the in the living room and he said I
got a bad feeling there was a video that
was out and he said you remember the
shirt I was wearing that Vinnie Vine
shirt
in my mind I was saying I don't remember
of any Vines sure it was the polo shirt
I didn't really know whether he was
trying to
get me to say that that was a shirt he
was wearing yet arguably the state's
strongest piece of evidence was the
infamous kennel video the recording
taken off of Paul's phone that places
Alec Murdock at the crime scene minutes
before Paul and Maggie were murdered
the one question that remained is why
would Alec Murdock kill his wife and son
the motive was he had Financial pressure
bearing down on him in June of 2021 from
a number of sources so now it was going
to come out most likely that he had
stolen 3.5 million dollars the law firm
confronting him on June 7th the day of
Paul and Maggie's murders and they said
there's 792 thousand dollars missing I
said I have reason to believe that you
received the ferris money directly to
you and you need to prove to me that you
did not the state felt he needed to
divert the attention away from all these
Financial pressures and then there was
the defense there's no direct evidence
there's no eyewitness
there's no camera there's no
fingerprints there's no forensics tying
him to the Grind none there are a number
of things coming into this trial that
seem to be problematic for the
prosecution there's no blood on him they
didn't find any blood on him what's the
explanation for not having blood on
himself this would have been a bloody
mess the defense also argued that the
state's theory of the shooting could be
off my opinion is the totality of the
evidence is more suggestive of a
two-shooter scenario why would one
shooter bring two long rifles two long
weapons to the event you can't handle
and shoot two of them whoever shot this
shot or these shots well first of all
the quail band shot was five two to five
four that is the most likely explanation
yes I think the defense presented
evidence to try to show that Alec
murdick really didn't fit the build of
the person who committed the murders
because of the evidence we heard about
trajectory they also suggested this
investigation was botched but there was
a body footprint near his that turned
out to be law enforcement correct yes
is that preservation of the scene that
your standards require not exactly no do
we know what other evidence they may
have destroyed I have no idea that's
right we don't when we come back this
whole trial changes when one person
decides it's time for the jury to hear
his side of the story what is your
decision I am going to testify I want to
testify
[Music]
the evidence will show he killed Maggie
and Paul here is the law
he didn't do it
in early 2023 the world watched the Alec
Murdoch murder trial unfold the once
prominent attorney now accused of
shooting to death his wife Maggie and
Son Paul by the dog kennels on their
family property the prosecution
presented compelling evidence such as
video from Paul's phone placing Murdoch
at the crime scene minutes before the
killings they also suggested that
Murdoch a substance abuser and defendant
in separate Financial related crimes
cases of killing his family because he
was about to be exposed for stealing
money from his law firm and clients and
the murders would be a distraction and
buy him some time while there was one
man who wanted to set the record
straight and that was Alec Murdock
himself I didn't shoot my wife or my son
any time
ever and that is when Alec Murdock
shocked everyone Mr murdick is that you
on the kennel video it is
were you in fact at the kennels at 8 44
PM I was did you lie to sled agent Owen
and deputy
Laura Rutland I did lie to them I don't
think Alec Murdock had any choice but to
take the stand because of the kennel
video
he had to explain why he lied as my
addiction evolved over time
I would get any situations or
circumstances where I would get paranoid
he did really quite well in my opinion I
thought credible believable
um
showed appropriate emotion he even
seemingly admitted to the financial
crimes he was accused of perpetrating I
stole money that was not my money I
misled people that I shouldn't have
misled and I did wrong he's a liar and
he's a thief and he readily admitted
that on the stand but he said you know I
might be these things but I didn't kill
my wife and son while Murdoch says he
was at the crime scene he claims he left
right before the murders however
prosecutor Creighton Waters wasn't
having it the reality is Mr Murdoch is
the reason why no one's ever heard that
before is because you had to sit in this
courtroom and hear your family and your
friends one after the other come in and
testify that you were on that kennel
video so you like you've done so many
times over the course of your life had
to back up and make a new story that
kind of fit with the facts that can't be
denied isn't that true sir no sir that's
not true putting Alex on the stand was
the single dumbest move by ever seen
when you have a guy that's a an admitted
liar indictment for murder guilty
verdict there's a lot of evidence that
points towards Alex he can't you know
deny that he was there at that point
because there's a video that places him
there somebody that couldn't speak
somebody that couldn't be a witness was
able to be a witness even after they had
passed away I think that he's good at
being able to talk to people and I think
that whenever he's convincing he's
convincing himself as well and I think
he's able to do that because he often
meshes the truth with a lie Mr Meadow I
sentence you in the murder of your wife
Maggie murdaugh a sentence you for the
term of the rest of your natural life
for the murder of Paul
murder
whom you probably love so much
I sentenced you to prison
for murdering him
for the rest of your natural life
Alec Murdoch's legal team intends to
appeal the case but right after the
trial ended a new update surfaced in the
story of Stephen Smith whose death
fueled rumors of a Murdoch family
connection I had been asleep and when I
woke up I saw that there were three
phone calls from Chief Mark Keel and he
said well I'm going to communicate to
you now the state of South Carolina's
official position and that is Steven
Smith did not die as a result of a
vehicle accident or Collision he was in
fact a victim of a homicide and we're
committed to finding out who killed
Stephen Smith
at the time of this recording the Alec
Murdoch conversation is continuing
there's still his appeal the Steven
Smith investigation upcoming Financial
crimes cases look there are many things
that can be said about Alec Murdoch yet
more than anything he is just another
example of someone who is not above the
law
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime thank you for joining us and until
next time stay safe
thank you
[Music]
foreign